اتهمت الخارجيه الروسيه اوكرانيا والامم
المتحده بعرقله مبادره البحر الاسود لنقل
الحبوب الاوكرانيه من خلال الاساءه في
استخدام نظام الاجراءات المطلوبه وبطلب
ريشن من مالك السفن وقالت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجي الروسيه ماريا زخروبا في بيان ان
مركز التنسيق المشترك في اسطنبول يواجه
صعوبات في تسجيل السفن الجديده وعمليه
التفتيش نتيجه للتصرفات ممثل اوكرانيا
والامم المتحده وفق قولها واضافت زخروبا
قائله ان السلطات كييف بعد ان تجاهلت بشكل
كامل كل الاعتبارات الانسانيه والحد
الادنى من الاخلاق تحاول استغلال مبادره
البحر الاسود بشتى الطرق باساءه استخدام
نظام الاجراءات وبطلب ريش من مالكي السفن
من اجل الحصول على اقصر ربح تجاري وفق
قولها هذا واوردت وكاله رويترز نقلا عن
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني اوليكسوندر ك
وبراكوف ان عمليه التفتيش السفن في اطار
مبادره البحر الاسود قد استانفت من جديد